[Music]
hop on my camel and chase you to the
North Pole
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it goes
what you're talking about purity pie and
I'm making any sense
oh you'll be high wearing your t-shirt
go up and try but you'll never be as
beautiful as PewDiePie picking on
YouTube in a tutu
woohoo I'm gonna need you when you the
soldier deeds getting a huge refuse
badami Jews with juice and ready to lose
these noobs
I'm a velociraptor ferocious a new
subscriber every day since Diplodocus um
clearly the don't piss the rest of you
are hopeless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you talking about cutie pie you
know making any sense wrong you'll be
hot you can wear my new Gucci suit and
groovy time but you'll never be Edgar
Allen are you responsible for what I'm
smiling I'm Lily Robin and baby babbling
MIDI hoping the Dermody stopping me or
whatever you're watching you and me
stopping appealing to the P even sweeter
than a dude like a [ __ ] stuck
in there stuck it makes me wanna play
like what the [ __ ] is that genius again
[Music]
[Music]
you could have a new goat movie but you
beautiful half ago I bet hope you bros
enjoyed this song thanks so much to
danville for making ed and h Brune for
this amazing animation and lil deuce
deuce for remix in it if you got this
song right now on iTunes I love a link
to all their channels down below go
check them out and subscribe to them
because they're awesome